i want to start by introducing cameron
teitelman who is the founder of startx
it started out as a uh essentially as a
project that he started as a student
here when he was a student in the
management science and engineering
department and then ended up spinning
out into a very exciting venture so i'm
going to hand it to cameron to introduce
the other panelists
hi everyone i'm cameron teitelman tina
thanks for the warm introduction
just a couple years ago sitting in your
seat so i'm very honored and privileged
to be here so our panelists today are
some uh very very impressive people way
more impressive than me so they'll have
a lot more to say than i will um our
first is joseph huang good friend of
mine he was in a very early session of
stardx the second session
his company wi-fi slam does indoor
positioning and i'll let him talk a
little bit more about that um about uh
was it oh he can't say but uh about a
year ago uh his company got acquired by
apple for around 30 million dollars um a
couple years after founding
these guys were out of the phd program
at stanford and so um i'm sure he'll be
happy to talk about his starbucks
experience and then we have siddha
sexena so
um
smita was a math and computational
sciences masters student at stanford
was in the first program of stardex and
actually went through and second went
through another program at startx a
couple years later she her first program
was a financial advisory company that
sold
and then she well i'll let her talk a
little bit about the other ones but she
reformed another company and went
through
then we have milt mccall
um milt's one of the eirs that went
through stardx and he was with us for
about a year
um his company
is is really fascinating puts the ipad
in the operating room to monitor blood
loss
and uh milt i'm not sure if he'll say
this so i'll just say it for him but he
was an undergrad at stanford and he was
a
medical school student and while he was
in medical school he won two super bowl
rings for the nfl for the 49ers
um and then he found a couple bio tech
companies did a few things like manage
the the venture fund for stanford's
athletic school
and um
um and now he's found in this company
i also want to add that he was a
classmate of mine at stanford medical
school so go mill
great so let's start out we you um
assume of course that everybody knows
what startx is maybe you can tell us a
little bit about what it is so that we
all have a shared understanding
yeah so at the core startx is a
community of of high potential founders
out of stanford and as an organization
we organize them to help each other
we do this in a bunch of different ways
and one of them is we have an
accelerator program it's basically a
10-week program where you have to have
at least one stanford founder on your
team you come in we figure out what you
want to learn and then by the end of
that 10 weeks we help you learn that
we also help develop specific skills
that in our initial research setting up
the program we found stanford alums did
or had learned to be successful so in
the initial stages when i was actually
in e145 which is tom the class that tom
byers who started stvp put together
i went out and talked around 220
stanford alums to figure out what made
them successful
and out of that research
we figured out some patterns and some
skills that they developed that made
them successful and a certain type of
network they had formed around
themselves and so stardx is a is an
attempt to
educate entrepreneurs who are building
companies out of stanford help them
develop those skills and manage the
extended network that develops so
let's pass the mic to these other folks
because
it would be really great to hear why
they chose to be at startx clearly the
three of you on the panel could have
started a company anywhere why did you
decide to take part in the startx
program great so uh we'll start with my
story um so as cameron mentioned we were
in one of the very early programs and so
um we were just grad students software
in uh in computer science 2011
and we were in the process of starting
our own company
and and maybe didn't quite really
understand uh what it what it really
entailed
and we had applied to startx mostly
because other entrepreneurs had told us
hey this is a really interesting thing
to do
but once we had got in it didn't take
very long to realize
this is an incredible incredible
opportunity
and if nothing else
just an opportunity to spend you know
your day-to-day with some of the other
top entrepreneurs from around stanford
and future leaders and visionaries of
silicon valley i think is priceless and
maybe we didn't even appreciate that
enough
when we started
cool
yeah so to kind of echo joseph's
thoughts um
i was you know again i was also a grad
student and i also didn't do my
undergrad at stanford so i wasn't really
familiar with the whole idea of startups
i came out to stanford and was taking
classes and you kind of get sucked in
that's all everyone talks about and
everyone's like when are you going to
start your next thing
um and so
you know i took a class i learned how to
code and we had a product and had no
clue what to do to start a company and
so we were actually part of startup's
first class i remember our interview was
at um
it was trusted her
you know really nerve-wracking no i mean
we have seven minutes to explain your
business and we built a little project
in class and we had to kind of make it
sound compelling
but cameron you know was really nice and
all the mentors are really great and
they saw something and i think that's
kind of their job is to take something
very raw and mold it into a company that
eventually got sold
and um you know even in terms of the
practical matters like you know how do
you structure your company what are the
legal matters other entrepreneurs who've
been through it what are the pitfalls
how do you even think about fundraising
when should you be fundraising i mean
these are all questions that even know i
should be asking myself before i got
into stardex so um i mean i guess
i mean helped me the first time and then
i came back the second time and it's
been just as helpful and this is a
bigger company so it's been exciting
so my introduction to startx really was
a little different i had been in
industry for 25 years i had been in
startup companies i'd been in venture
capital so i was pretty familiar with
the whole process but i'd come back to
stanford to do some mentoring at the
stanford biodesign program
and ironically they were short a
business student that one quarter and
the the guy who leads it paul yach asked
if i would actually be the business
student on a team and i thought well
that sounds kind of fun i actually never
went to business school so i'm not sure
how i could have qualified for that but
um but i ended up meeting the uh the
co-founder of the company uh
at the end of the course we ended up
sort of deciding to start a company not
based on that that uh project that it
had but a different different one he had
had going on and the next thing i'd say
a few months later he asked me one day
if i'd be the ceo of the company and so
it's been two and a half years and it's
been a great experience
we were fortunate because he knew about
stardex i'd been around stanford for
years and knew nothing about it in fact
i had been trying to start something
like this in the medical side
at stanford but but being a being an
alum and having a bunch of people trying
to help me i realize it's really the
students that get things done so
somebody like cameron it took someone
like him to actually get this started
and then i was able to join into it and
be a part of it it's been a great
community and i i feel like
you know i feel like i have i have
something to offer some of these other
i'd say younger younger students or
alumni on the other hand many of them
teach me stuff i know nothing about
ipads and software and all this i'm
learning you know up to my ears on stuff
now
so cameron maybe you can help us
understand
the relationship between startx and
stanford um i have to say i've been here
long enough that i remember the days
when stanford was allergic to the idea
of having any sort of incubation or
acceleration programs basically saying
listen silicon valley is one big
incubator you know why do we need
something like that so maybe you could
tell us about the how this came to be
and and what the relationship with
stanford is now
yeah so i'll start with how this came to
be and i mentioned it i mentioned it
briefly um so i built two companies when
i was at stanford two completely
different companies one was a private
equity company and it was an advertising
company and
i i learned
a lot about entrepreneurship
specifically through the msne program i
took e145 i went to all the etl classes
and
and when i was building my company i
found that i needed to learn a lot of
really practical things and i kept kind
of hitting my head against the wall
trying to learn it trying to learn it
and then um i would go and talk to my
friends or i'd find some i'd go to a
networking event and find some mentor
but i'd still it seemed really
inefficient
i got this really solid foundational
education but after that it didn't seem
like there was much support even in
silicon valley i go talk to investors
and you know to be honest silicon valley
is a great place and it's a very let's
say meritocratic and honest place but
there's still people who will do shady
things and so when i was talking to
other friends who built companies there
was a lot of issues they saw in silicon
valley so what i did is i did what i
learned in steve blank's class here
is i just got out of the building and
started talking to customers and after
talking to hundreds
this theme emerged where after
after a couple years they finally
figured out how to be effective in
silicon valley and so the people who
built 100 million companies or 50
million companies figured out hey if i
have the right support system around
myself
i'll be successful
and they wish they knew it earlier and
then people who failed would say
i wish i'd known how to build the
support system around myself because
when you're in a large company you can
go to hr you can go to legal you can
learn all these different things
um so after talking to them it was very
clear that there was this big missing
educational need and there's this
problem where if you could just
structure the resources of silicon
valley they existed in a in a certain
way the process for building your
company out of the university could be
ten times more efficient and so the idea
with stardex wasn't to let's say create
new entrepreneurs it was to increase the
speed of innovation
and decrease the friction with
people who will be they might be
successful anyway
but if we could move the needle on
people who weren't successful to be
successful and make the successful
people even more successful that adds to
solving problems in the world
and so stanford the relationship with
stanford initially
and you can look back in this you know
people were wondering
why are these guys doing what they're
doing is this an incubator in the
classic sense are we going to waste
students time by supporting them
if they shouldn't be supported if they
should be thrown out into the wild of
silicon valley
and it was very clear from our research
that it was something that was needed
and so
you know we pushed forward we built
something we we launched it to our
customers we iterated on it and a couple
years later stanford has said hey like
this is great this provides a lot of
value to our community so initially we
are legally separate from stanford
university as part of the student
government
and then after a couple of years we spun
out of the student government as a
legally separate entity we set a lot of
relationships on campus and then earlier
this year or
late last year stanford was uh you know
after talking to president hennessy and
the cfo of stanford president hennessey
is the c uh the president of stanford
for those of you don't know
they decided that they want to
financially support us to help us grow
even further so now they're giving us
around a 1.2 million dollar grant a year
and
to help in our operations
um and then separately we have a fund
with them and the fund is a
non-discretionary fund
that any company who goes through startx
any participant can pull 10 of their
funding round from the fund and so um
you know i think like any startup like
we consider startups a startup we had a
kind of rocky start where people didn't
really understand us but now we've kind
of broken through which is great it
would be super to hear from the folks on
the panel about maybe some interesting
example of something you gained out of
this i mean it's it's particularly
interesting for the folks who um came
with very different backgrounds right
either folks who had come out of classes
where you were taught um a bunch of
foundational material or even um
milt you know you you were a vc
so you had a lot of background you know
what sort of benefit are you getting
from being this type of experience so
i
there's there's too many great things
about startups to give you one answer um
so maybe i'll just start the so first of
all
you know we got there and as cameron
mentioned we were one of the very early
sessions and so we didn't really know
what to expect either
but it only took you know a couple weeks
before we realized this isn't your
typical startup accelerator we've done
some research you know to try to
understand what a startup accelerator
was in silicon valley and what really
they do
and you know for example we would walk
in
and surrounding us there were more first
of all there were more graduate students
undergrads right there are people there
using building game changing
technologies and in very very
interesting businesses it wasn't just
you know a bunch of people making
facebook for cats
um
and and you know like and i touched on
this earlier
in hindsight the greatest value we got
was just spending day to day with some
of the top entrepreneurs from stanford
at that time who are going to become
future leaders and future visionaries in
silicon valley and
and you know we got to like i got to sit
in a chair beside these people
every day but let's dig down into that
though did you spend time discussing
your problems with them the challenges
was their formal programming where you
were working together i think it's
incredible how much you can absorb and
learn when you're both trying to tackle
startup
raw startup problems at your desks
beside each other you know when we had a
sales problem and it was just hey this
these people aren't responding the same
way we thought and they're you know they
hate they
some other you know jet lord game closer
anyone sitting across the table and say
hey you know we ran into that situation
we tried this it worked well we tried
this it didn't work well
people had gone through recruiting
people had gone through uh patent
strategy um pricing the whole thing
company i can go on forever that all the
things you really need to do when you
build a company there's just great minds
around you and it's not just people who
are there trying to tell you their
stories because they're building their
companies too
i can go on forever i don't know that's
great
okay
that was perfect
um
yeah so as joseph mentioned um startix
attracts great people and um for us i
think it really at least for my second
company spot on especially really laid
the foundation of how we built the
company to start off with so when i um
sold my first company i took some time
off and i reached back to out of cameron
being like hey look i think i'm ready to
get back into the startup space i may do
another startup and so he was like yeah
sure come out you know check out the
news startx space and i did and i was
blown away it was massive there's so
many more teams like as joseph mentioned
that it was this whole collegiate you
know atmosphere which was which was
great to see and through that process i
found my new co-founder which was great
again he was kind of the same stage that
i was at late nights talking about the
problems that we were excited about and
through that we also found our lead
investor again another stardex mentor
who really liked us fell in love with
the idea that we're working on and was
like sure i'll back you
put together our seed round for us and
again through startups we found our
first employee and our next four
employees as well so what startups i
guess really serves that is as is a
really good filter for the kinds of
people you want to be working with and
the kinds of people who can help elevate
your business down the line
and also the same time it's just really
fun people i mean it's very rare to find
you know smart people who are really
driven but at the same time have
personalities and are interesting and in
friends i mean i'm glad joseph that i
met you and then we get to hang out
and so from that perspective it's been
great for building memories as well as
you know startup
so i can remember the first thing i
learned the first day at startups i'm an
early riser and i i got up as usual
early to get to work and i walked in the
door and i i saw a few people that
already said i've never been people
beating me to work in the morning would
actually recognize these were students
that had been there all night long and
they're just leaving in a few minutes so
so i learned that the the the uh
the culture is very different obviously
but
i'd say i thought a great example was i
was sitting at my desk and startups has
a bunch of tables and all the founders
sit around them and it's very it's a big
community is what it really is and i was
chatting with the person next to me and
who was our director of engineering said
gosh we're having trouble with apple you
know they have these ipads and we can't
figure out how to make this work and all
of a sudden somebody turns around and
says oh we did that last week with apple
we met with this guy named joe and
here's his phone number call him and
he'll fix it for you so it's this kind
of collaboration community that really
makes things helpful there and in the
same hand i've been working in the
medical device industry for 25 years i
mean some of the companies are they have
a startup's med group and
so i i remember having a lunch session
one time we just started talking about
the fda and how to deal with efd and i'd
spent 25 years dealing with the fda
nobody can ever deal with the fda but
there are some tricks to to working with
them there are sort of things that are
helpful to know and so i was able to
share some of that so i think that that
whole part of being able to help your
co-founders is really what's incredible
about the place
so i'm curious cameron how do you pick
people i understand that these days it's
harder to get into starbucks than it is
to get into stanford so uh what's the
process of picking people because
clearly the community folks that you
have under that roof is very special and
that that's a huge part of what makes it
valuable
yeah so
to preface that we're a 501c3 nonprofit
and we have an educational mission and
so what we want to do is we want to
empower as many entrepreneurs as we
possibly can
and so when we were initially starting a
lot of the reason why stanford didn't
want they were allergic to this idea of
an incubator is they didn't want people
who
shouldn't be building the companies to
be building companies like they actually
they didn't want phd students to just do
it because it was cool they wanted them
to if they were going to build a company
to do it because they were really
passionate about the problem that they
were solving and a lot of people in the
2000s were getting funded just just like
money thrown at them and so they wasted
a lot of their time just working on
problems that weren't useful like
facebook for cats
and so
one of our core criteria for accepting
people is that they have an intrinsic
passion for the problem that they're
solving
they also have to have an ambition to
solve it a large scale so motivation and
passion are our number one criteria
the second is team dynamics so we don't
just accept excellent entrepreneurs
we want them to be in highly functioning
teams
entrepreneurship is very lonely it's
very hard a core part of the value we
provide we actually have kind of like a
in-house uh therapist psychologist like
the d school at stanford does
but one of the core values we provide is
positive psychological motivation
because a lot of times when you're by
yourself coding alone in the basement
or building alone in your in your lab
it can get isolating and so
providing people with a community of
peers they can benchmark against that
they can talk to about problems they
can't talk to investors about or mentors
and provides a lot of value so
having that core team that you trust
that you love working with and that
complements your skills
solves a lot of problems that companies
face and i think noam wasserman at
harvard said 70 of companies fail
because of team dynamic issues so team
dynamics is number two the third is
ability to build and build quickly
so just like um you know steve blank's
concepts and the lean startup you have
to iterate quickly even in the medical
device even in even in the medical
industry we try to push companies for
this so they need to be highly
technically proficient in what they're
building
in order to iterate quickly so we
actually do technical screening and
technical interviews on biotech
companies on stem cell companies on i.t
hardware across the board and the final
and least important criteria to us is
the idea
and that's kind of is like weird to
people sometimes why is the idea
the least important thing well it's
important that our founders and
especially the ceos have good strategic
minds
so they can talk about the problem and
lay out and break down and reduce the
problem that they're tackling in an
intelligent way and then when challenged
on something incorporate that and listen
well
and so
sometimes people can't listen or
founders don't want to listen and
they're too stubborn to listen and that
doesn't work you can't iterate if you
don't do that
so they need to be thinking through the
idea correctly however everyone knows
well
you know people like you know who
understand this space the initial idea
you start with
always changes but it's important to us
that the problem they're trying to solve
always stays true because they're
intrinsically motivated by it how
exactly they're solving it can change
and that's the framework we use so how
long do people typically stay there i
know that one session is is three months
it's like it's a quarter
how long do people do they say one two
three
so most of them out yeah exactly most
people stay one there's a couple teams
that stay multiple quarters
so for instance our medical program is
six months long because there's a longer
iteration cycle for medical companies um
early on we had a company a great female
founder named karina pickard who built a
braille labeler a more cheap and
efficient braille labeler and that was a
hardware company and so she stayed on
three sessions because the product
iteration cycles are longer
so usually we say well you can stay on
if you're going to become part of the
staff and help the next founders
you can stay on if
you really need help and then we
actually do kick people out if they're
not making tough decisions
there's one more aspect about this too
which is
stanford
and startx are these are these
communities that are really powerful and
it's not how many sessions you're
enrolled in startx that makes a
difference it's the connections and
bonds you form and utilize with the
people who you connect with and bond
with while you're there forever
that matter um right and like we're
still getting help from people in startx
today as well as people we interacted
with at startx while we were there um
and i don't think that's ever gonna end
so technically we're in an infinite
number of sessions so that's a really
good way to look at it i'm curious about
the transition out you know is that an
easy transition does it feel like you're
leaving the nest or is it something you
know you're getting kicked out or is
that a really seamless process as you go
from being in stardex to then basically
flying on your own
spend you want to remember
go for it so i'll answer it so we
actually were there a little over a year
ourselves and and we really felt like it
was helpful for us um but what happened
to us is the company got a little bit
bigger and so we ended up needing our
own space that's always helpful i think
just because
i mean that's part of the issue but i
think what joseph mentioned is
even the moment we left you're still
connected everywhere from physically you
come in and visit and be part of it but
but through the net and things i mean i
would say we're looking for to hire
people we send the word out and the next
thing you know we have startups people
telling us things or or we have somebody
coming by friday that's an expert in
marketing as we're getting ready to
launch our product from you know cameron
sends out a message there's somebody
that's that's here that would like to
help so it's this constant communication
that goes on i think that really makes
so different
yeah um and i think you know again um
similar to what you said the constant
communication definitely helps but even
when we transitioned out i think it was
great that we our office is right beside
another startup's office um start a
company's office and it's great you know
we get to hang out still solve some of
the same problems and the community kind
of comes with you and you know we try to
have events after as well and stay
connected and it's been being alumni is
i guess is not as different as being
still part of the program you still hang
around and are involved great so the
community lives on so can you talk a
little bit about the business model you
know this is an interesting in a lot of
accelerate accelerators or incubators uh
they take uh equity uh they're they're
all different ways in which this work
can you tell us about the business model
for startups yeah so one of the uh let's
say
what people say is a big differentiator
of us is that we charge founders nothing
we don't take any equity there's no cost
it's completely free
um so the question is how do we how do
we sustain ourselves it's crazy right
um
well the core idea behind stardex is a
collaborative community of founders that
helps each other and so we we didn't
want to charge for that we didn't want
to put up a barrier to get excellent
people in and these guys can talk a
little bit about about that
um and so what we do is we figure out
what our founders need help with and and
who they can get help from and go to
them and
ask them to pay us to be able to help
them and it's kind of a weird a weird
thing so we have partnerships with
companies like microsoft and intuit and
on the medical side johnson johnson
genentech and j and j
um vc firms like sequoia capitals of
partner and greylock and dfj is a
partner as well um and so they help us
they well part of the part of it is they
they they believe in the values of our
program and our mission so they want to
support another part of is they want to
get in front of these founders and and
so
we've always been really stubborn and
never creating uh an exclusive
partnership because
we want to have a level playing field
for all of our partners and that's part
of our revenue um we've actually uh the
only let's say a donation-based revenue
we've ever taken is from the blackstone
foundation and then we had a large grant
from the kauffman foundation in the past
to produce a work product that's half of
our revenue the other half's coming from
stanford right now
so what we're saying is we're going to
bring in excellent people we're going to
help them learn from each other and
we're going to give visibility to people
and that visibility is basically what
people pay for on the partnership side
and on the university side we're going
to say hey look
jerry yang you never jerry yang never
gave a percentage of his company to
stanford stanford didn't know anything
but
both president hennessey and the
university had a great relationship with
him and so he ended up you know building
a building here
and so what we're able to do for
stanford is drive donations through
through basically uh engagement and
we're able to help them with their fund
with our fund basically um so yeah
that's our business model great it's
working well super so
who is there you know when this started
i remember it was students right
students could it was almost like taking
instead of taking a quarter abroad they
could take a quarter at this you know
accelerator to work on their projects
now i understand that most of the people
are participating are
graduates and and even alumni you know
so milt you know i know how many years
you've been out of school it's a same as
i have
so uh i'm curious um you know what was
the reason why you switched from really
focusing on on students to alumni so
when you say participating um do you
mean like the staff the people i don't
mean the staff i mean the startups the
founders
right it used to be that it was students
students who were working on companies
in their dorm rooms would come and spend
a quarter now it's folks who are uh
graduates
that i don't i don't know if that's
exactly accurate um
you know when we were in the program it
was a mix of both students and people
who had come out from you know further
alums of stanford for example in our
session um there was lark who was making
sort of a uh you know a sleep tracking
iphone accessory uh diffbot was making
they're sort of using computer vision to
solve unsolved problems in web parsing
there was there was a number of people
who
added incredible value to us personally
as well as to our company as well as to
the communities
and these were already they were already
stanford alumni when we had gone through
the program
and then today
i think you still have a mix i'm you
know i was taking part in the stardex
community events and things we still
have many people who are students as
well as probably the same mix of people
who
have more industry experience to offer
okay and i'll i'll um
you know clarify the initial intention
with stardex so our first summer we took
people who are currently in school and
people who are graduating and then the
following fall we were wondering hmm can
we actually support people who are still
in school is it possible and through
that we had a company um clear ear
lily trung who who was spending 70 hours
a week on her company on top of school
and she was finishing up her classes
and she just needed some support and so
we were able to help her and when i was
building my companies at stanford i was
spending 80 hours a week on my company
and so what startx really is for are
people who are going to dive into
building a company you know they're
going to do it regardless of whether
we're there or not that's actually
something we vet for um
and because they they're so crazy
passionate about the problem that
they're solving that they're going to do
it and so if people are still in school
and they're spending full-time hours and
working really hard and spending time at
stardex
or spending time with the company we'll
bring them into the accelerator program
now that doesn't mean we don't still
support other members of the community
now one thing we do for instance is
anyone who applies to startx
anyone we cap we get feedback from all
the judges online and in person and we
do office hours for anyone and we sit
down and spend hours hundreds of hours
giving feedback because it's extremely
valuable you don't really get that you
go to a vc you pitch they say goodbye
because we love you it's it's
it's it's me not you um and they don't
really give that hard feedback and so we
do that
um and then and then you know what's
happened is we we have that segment
that's that's like leaving the
university working full-time in the
company and what we've done is as our
brand has grown we've gotten more and
more people later stage
and so the percentage of non-students
has grown but the uh the absolute amount
is stayed relatively the same and what
we're doing moving forward is we're
moving three blocks off campus
um to this uh 12 600 square foot
building
that the the person who designed the d
school at stanford is designing it
and we'll be moving in there in two
weeks
and so over the next three months we're
actually spending that doing this thing
called
this initiative called openx
and
we're trying to take our accelerator
program and what we've learned from it
what we've learned from supporting the
extended community and open that up to
more earlier stage in students and so
we're working with stvp and the gsb and
having lots of events there
and trying to you know focus on saying
okay well we kind of nailed this segment
of the population now let's provide
value to more people we're not profit
terrific so in a minute i'm going to
open it up to questions from the
audience so start thinking about your
probing questions about startex so
i
clearly a huge value comes from the
community of folks who are working there
um i understand you also bring in a lot
of mentors and coaches maybe you can
talk a little bit about uh what sort of
people are involved in helping and what
they get out of it yeah absolutely so so
there's kind of four things that we
provide one is community which these
guys have talked a lot about um two is
mentorship and we have a bunch of
different mentorship structures from
serial entrepreneurs who are lead
mentors to an advisory board
for instance on the medical advisory
board of a company they'll have a doctor
in the cfo of a hospital to experts
hundreds of experts i think around 500
that can come in and get on phone calls
do office hours that sort of thing um
but i'll actually pass it over to these
guys they're all mentored and in fact we
bring our alums back to mentor the other
founders so maybe you can talk about um
what what you would get out of it and
what your mentors get out of it sure um
yeah we so there are plenty of people
who offered great great help to us i'll
just pick out a couple um jay bornstein
was our lead mentor when we were through
the program um you know he's a he's a
professor here um he was a grad student
in computer science just like we were he
started his company sort of not not
really knowing what to do just like we
did and you know what was really
interesting i think was that startx is
able to pair you
i'm not i think it's because they have
zero percent equity it's sort of they
don't have an incentive they're not
purchasing mentorship right you when you
find that mentor which who's exactly
was you in your footsteps several years
ago and built a successful company it's
it's a perfect match you both want to i
you want to get help and then they want
to help you um and i think when you sort
of open it up you have a zero percent
equity you have this this really
interesting dynamic you get you get
super tailored help and we couldn't have
done anything we did without jay
bornstein's impact and he was he's
always been incredible and you you've
sold your company now and so but you
come back and help out other stars i
think yeah a lot of companies will come
back and help and i think it's just so
tremendous even while we were running
wi-fi slam
the minute it was possible as soon as i
had tried sort of this mentoring other
companies going through the program i
realized i had way more to gain from me
like you know sharing what i'd learned
and lessons i'd learned with them
then perhaps even they have to gain from
these lessons themselves
um yeah so i'll give you a couple
examples first of all um it's really
hard
to be objective with your own company
when it's your baby when it's something
you're working on you want to get
perfect and you're you're every hour of
the day you're trying to you know while
you sleep you're trying to figure things
out and sometimes you just can't think
clearly about it but when you're sitting
there and it's another company maybe
they're not in your domain maybe they're
not um they don't say background as you
and you're looking at you're like but
that
that doesn't make sense why would a
startup why would you want to do that
and then you walk out of that meeting
you realize why do i why am i doing what
i'm doing
right um but you know it goes much
further than that i think
it's really inspiring as startx
continues to raise the bar for people
they bring in um you know you'll get to
mentor teams that you know learn lessons
that they've learned while they're
building their companies you know and it
helps you too it's sort of like two
basketball stars sort of comparing notes
at the all-star game right you
you can't possibly learn everything on
your own and
they as part of the mentorship process
they have to report their progress to
you and sometimes they'll show up and
they'll say hey we had this really
interesting sales tactic and we went in
there and worked great and it's worked
three times out of four
and you'll say hey you know let me take
notes this is really interesting um
and sometimes they'll just inspire you
like sometimes you're you know starting
a startup is like a roller coaster as
i'm sure you've heard a thousand times
and and sometimes it just takes you know
another team pushing as hard as they can
to overcome adversity for you to say all
right
i'm going to strap in i'm going to do it
too and so it just i could go on forever
as always
yeah so so so i learned in life early on
that there's nothing free in life and
although they don't take equity there
there is a there's a commitment
and the commitment is you're you're part
of the code and the code is you help out
your fellow co-founders and every every
founder is extremely busy you they work
18 19 hours a day we pulled all nighters
there i haven't pulled on there since
medical school and here i was pulling an
all-nighter at start x one night
and it's just part of the code yet the
same hand when one of your founders next
to you has a problem and it's something
you can help out with it's your
obligation to stop what you're doing and
help them and it is a very interesting
culture here because it and it works it
works because that's what everyone
expects of you when you go there so they
help you and you help them and that's
what makes the the the system work
right so i had the pleasure of sitting
on a board actually with joseph right
yeah so i remember and this and these
are also words of wisdom from joseph i
will admit this um so it was a company
they were presenting and they were
getting reamed by all of us and um i
felt terrible because i mean here's the
founders i mean obviously they're
they're very passionate about what
they're doing and we just disagree and
then a comment was made and this is
always stuck with me it's like you know
if you tell someone you want to build a
rocket ship no one's going to ask
questions if you tell someone you're
going to paint the shed suddenly
everyone's going to be going on about
what color
and so that's exactly what's happening
and then you kind of start thinking
about well wait i've been in this
situation before when when i when you
know when have i been painting the shed
and no one pointed it out to me so it
was it's moments like that you know when
you when you feel
like okay great this is i'm at the right
place and this is you know i'm learning
just as much as these guys are learning
and i'm really glad to be part of this
whole process and i think startups is a
good is a great job of kind of making
that happen because they take into
account you know how i've worked in the
past how the other mentors have worked
in the past how we're gonna have rapport
with the team
and having few teams and having alumni
that are engaged kind of really makes it
easy to make that happen um so i really
appreciated that part of it yeah and and
of course uh something that's a core
staff value and the core value of
startups is feedback
and constantly getting feedback from
people around you your mentors your
customers most importantly um is
essential um so we get a lot of feedback
from our mentors and a lot of what our
mentors say well one there's an affinity
like this person was me and so i want to
help them
another is they actually learn a lot
like technology technological innovation
is so fast there's so much new stuff
happening that just by mentoring guys
like joseph you learn so much and then a
lot of them come to me and say oh i
learned this i'm going to bring it back
to my company now and talk to my
co-founders about it and so
you know these mentors are there because
they want to learn they want to
they want to help people who are in
their shoes and and um you know there's
a lot of people who want to get involved
in stanford who want to get involved in
startups just for deal flow for instance
or just to like get stuff out and we
actively vet those people out and we
constantly are getting feedback on them
and so if people you know misrepresent
something and they
are bad actors in this community
then they're out are they allowed to
invest if you're a mentor can you invest
not during the program so if you're
active if you have an active mentor
relationship with someone you can't as a
mentor you they actually they actually
like have to agree to something that
says they can't even like tell the
founder they're interested in investing
while they're mentoring them
now after the program or after the
mentorship relationship we we allow the
founders to make the decision we say hey
if you want them as an investor here's
the steps you need to go through to make
it an appropriate relationship and then
we warn if someone's mentoring you they
have inside information that they could
use against you in a negotiation so just
be careful about that um and then we are
again actively evaluating our mentors to
make sure that they you know won't do
things like that
interesting thank you so i bet there are
some questions who in the audience would
start
yes hi uh
so
hey cameron joseph smith um so we were
also at my company virginslabs is also a
stardex alum company and
um yeah one of the startups i want to
say is very awesome and one of the
things that we got out of it is that we
learned
we when we started we were trying to
build um sort of
a lot of
similar but different products at the
same time and actually advice from
cameron helped us focus on making this
product which
glasses that can capture the point of
the experience um so you know we've been
able to focus
get that manufactured um had it even
worn by macklemore you know that
investment from including return draper
so i want to say thank you to startx and
also my question is for companies that
are participating in startups what are
the recommendations for how to to learn
the most from that experience and then
companies that are startups alums um
what are the best ways to give back to
our community
can you just repeat the question yes so
yeah the questions are as a stardex uh
as a participant in a program like
startx or in stardex how do you get the
most out of it
one and then two as an alum
or a community member of stardex how do
you continue to get value and contribute
value
yeah so
i'll answer the first one first um
the the one thing i think
i tell every founder that enters the
program
that i wish i knew when we started to
sort of get as much as you can out of
the program is take the time to get to
know the other founders in your session
it's really really easy to be heads down
like
if you're an entrepreneur you love
working on your startup and you will do
that every day all the time
and and it takes a while you're only in
the session for 10 12 weeks um
and that first couple weeks no one
really knows anyone there's no
there they run events but but go out of
your way to get to know these people
they're all
super fantastic and and if you do that
you'll get blown away by who they are
and you'll have a better sense of how
you can really help them everyone is
trying to do a lot of stuff
and some things are just really really
easy for you because of your background
and really really hard for them because
of their background but it doesn't
matter because if you can save them
three weeks of time with two hours of
your time
it
you you just create a really really
interesting bond that will last perhaps
forever
um smith do you want to answer the
second question
i'm sure like how can alumni contribute
towards startx
um i think the best way and we've talked
about this already is mentoring and
staying in touch with the community
making sure that
if there are other companies kind of in
the field or somewhat related to you
that you can reach out and make sure
that you're helping
um but i think overall generally
speaking time's your worst enemy as a
startup you're always trying to solve
problems as quickly as possible and this
kind of again touches on jose's point is
that you really want to get to know the
founders whether they're alumni or the
existing class to make sure that you're
solving problems in a way that you know
other people have already tried it and
found an optimal solution
and so that way you can collaborate make
sure that you guys are reaching your
goal together
but at the same time making the most of
the program
great any another question
yes bruce
it sounds like you're building up an
enormous amount of social capital within
startups
have you started to track quantitatively
um how stardex founded companies or
mentor companies are doing versus some
of the other incubators in the valley
uh
yeah so the the question is how do we
quantitatively track the success of our
founders and our companies
um so again our core metric is what they
learn
and how what they learn translates to
impact in their company
and so we do track that we track how
many skills a founder learns they they
come and they say hey i want to learn
what this i want to learn this list and
then after being ripped apart by alums
and mentors they're like okay actually i
need to focus on this list
and then we do help them develop those
skills and then we ask them how does
that how did that actually impact your
company now that's on the non-profit
education side and there aren't really
other people that are doing that
on the let's say against for-profit
accelerators metric is usually funding
or average funding per company
um our average funding per company is
around 2.1 million per company
uh that makes us the number two
on that metric which for profit
accelerators use that makes us number
two in the world right behind y
combinator head attack stars 500 um
um
you know other other accelerators let's
say um and so
you know our companies have raised i
think
350 million there's 12 acquisitions um
and 85 or so 80 of our companies are
still going and funded
10 have gotten acquired and 10 have shut
down
um so in the startup world that those
are great numbers um and our core thesis
is if we can empower
high potential entrepreneurs and help
them develop skills to reach their
potential then they'll build successful
things and part of that potential that
john was talking about over here was
helping them focus
helping them throw stuff away if they
need to throw it away
and that that's all about uh helping
them critically think about the problems
they're solving
terrific
another question yes
mainly towards cameron but i was curious
in the earliest days of stardex
especially while you're a student here
um
what was it like trying to establish
these relationships with mentors
entrepreneurs without really having
this tangible metrics to show or as much
substance really go off and show off but
yeah
yeah so the question is um in the very
early stages when i was starting how
could i
what was it like building a network and
and building this relationships
relationships for to build startx
without anything
and i didn't come from a background
where my parents know a lot of people
um i was kind of a unit of one
and so
what i did is is the most one of the
most important things
when starting a company which is
figure out if you're solving a real
problem
very first thing and i with overwhelming
evidence i had
identified it was a real problem
you know 70 founders had you uniquely
said the same thing that yes i did this
and i'm so glad i did this i wish i'd
done it sooner
um but i'm unique and 70 people said
that so it's like okay there's a problem
here um and so with that problem then i
could craft a solution or a very clear
concise
explanation for what i wanted to do and
more importantly why
and so then when i went to
people and explained it they got it like
oh that makes sense here's the data that
backs it up
and so they agreed now the question is
okay even if they agree that's a problem
why would they think i can do it
um well that goes into salesmanship and
some other things but basically what i
did is what we teach startups founders
to do i went to one founder i thought
was great i asked them who are the other
founders you think are great and they
told me five people i went to all those
five people and said what other founders
do you think are great what mentors you
think are great and i went to those you
know five founders and 25 and five
mentors
and then i went to those mentors talked
to them and said hey which mentors do
you think are great and through that i
got warm referrals and connections
into hundreds of people
and then you start drawing this kind of
mesh network of who thinks who is great
and then telling people hey we're going
to do this thing when it happens you
want to be involved and here the other
people are going to be involved
and so it's kind of like building a
marketplace startup where you have this
kind of chicken in the egg problem and
we had discussions about that week over
week
so it was
it was like getting one getting the
other and using them to get more
terrific
another question
yes uh can you share how many jobs have
been created since starting study
yeah so i think um
yeah oh the question is how many jobs
have been created um so the last tally
was uh roughly around 500.
and so there's i think that we have a
different number now but it's it's
roughly around the 500 number i don't
know the exact stat right now
so what are your goals going forward you
know this is you you have built
something that is incredibly impressive
i mean i remember when this was an early
seat of an idea and you were you know
really um had a lot of headwinds you
know when you when you started out so
that you you've really done an
incredibly impressive job and and
clearly you know folks appreciate what
you've done what do you see is the goals
going you know five years down the line
yeah so the initial vision of stardex
was there's 40 000 companies that have
built been built at stanford
collectively they create 2.7 trillion
dollars of annual revenue that makes it
the 10th or 11th world's largest country
the people who are the most successful
leverage the group around them to be
more successful so the core vision of
startx was if in the past all those 40
000 people or companies were helping
each other
they could have created a lot more
impact
so the next step with stardex is saying
okay well if we can leverage the entire
stanford entrepreneurial network to help
itself
that could materially increase and
improve
both the skill development the access to
information and the access to people
so right now we've supported people five
years out of school a couple people like
milt um we've had a cs professor uh go
through the program monica lam a bunch
of medical school professors and so the
idea is okay well let's take this from
from this specific stage we're at of
really supporting companies in this
extended community to really helping the
entire stanford alumni entrepreneurial
community getting value providing them
value getting value from them for the
other founders
and then use that as a test case to
potentially go to other universities
and so or be a model other people can
replicate now there's a lot of
universities from harvard mit to other
places who have called us reached out to
us and tried to replicate components
and yeah just like the epicenter is
trying to
create more entrepreneurial engineers
all over the world and all over the
country we'd love to
provide a platform to for universities
and ecosystems to have a structured way
for networks to help themselves terrific
question yes you mentioned real world
solutions to problems and such so it's
not technology for technology's sake but
creating maybe a solution for instance
on something as big as global warming
and such
i know that's huge but um
so what type of criteria are you looking
for outside of just the engineer
to come in with with an idea to to
develop that's going to really create a
real real world solution
well so
so repeat the question oh uh
okay sounds like the question was what
criteria are there to make sure people
are solving
big problems for the world
um
and and i just want to
you know when we were in there we were
the second session i think they they
didn't have nearly as much
uh leverage to sort of bring in great
entrepreneurs but even us you know going
through our session to our left was a
company who had you know found a way to
transform skin cells into beating heart
cells so that they could do
you know live screening of drugs and
things on my right was a company who had
drastically transformed the economics
for solar heliostat technology using ai
and robotics and i mean
you know here we are we're just doing
indoor positioning for smartphones like
we're the ones that like really
um and and i think it's just inspiring
when you sit beside these people you ask
yourself
hey could i be doing something greater
too i think everyone motivates everybody
and so maybe it's not just the criteria
maybe it's just the environment
and i just want to re-emphasize what
cameron said earlier about start x in
terms of picking companies they don't
really look at the idea so much it's
really about the team because what you
find out is it's all about um pivoting i
mean so many ideas i mean i was in my
very first company and we started one
direction and within a year we were in a
completely different direction and we
ended up being very successful but it's
not necessarily about the idea it's
about the people getting together and
leveraging the thinking process and a
bunch of smart people that work really
hard it's amazing how successful they
can be together if they're working
collaboratively
back there
speak up really loud uh how much
cross-pollination is there between the
teams
uh like if do you recruit people from
other teams that are not doing as well
into your company and vice versa do you
lose members if you're struggling to
other teams that are doing better
i'm sure the question was how much
cross-pollination is there between teams
are teams recruiting from each other
i guess is that fair representation um
so
so like you know i think the common
theme for the whole night has been start
accepts great founders and you have
people of great caliber who are coming
in who want to work on great ideas um
there is
there's generally again you know like
good you
rule of thumb that you could basically
say that you know obviously you don't go
out there and steal anyone else's
employees but teams break apart
sometimes and you know things don't work
out and startx is a great place there to
kind of find where you want to fall
fall into
so for example for us um when i first
went to startx i was actually working
with someone else and we ended up not
working together and similarly my now my
co-founder was working with someone else
and they also didn't end up working
together and which is again having an
environment like startups which is very
safe and supportive it's perfectly fine
to experiment and things don't work out
and you move on
charles and i ended up working together
on spot on and it was great i mean at
that point in time it just clicked it
made sense um we were like we're
supposed to be co-founders and now we
can move on so in that way it is
partially true um that it does create
relationships where it wouldn't have
been otherwise
yeah so the uh one of the core things we
focus on is reducing the barrier for
people to help each other
and that's trust
and so we have certain community norms
around you know not poaching employees
and and not doing things that are shady
again
but then we also spend a lot of time
building trusted relationships between
the founders and creating rules around
engagement and what that does is it it
allows us we actually one session went
from 15 to 30 companies and the work for
the staff went down
it's like oh interesting and it went
down because we focus on providing uh
mechanisms for founders to teach each
other and reducing the barrier and so
yeah the core value we provide is
creating trust between founders so they
can help each other great
yes um do you know what the breakdown is
of participants coming from stem
backgrounds versus softer humanities
backgrounds
um
that get into the program or that apply
so
yeah so so i'm not sure about the
applicants
we definitely have way more way more
stem backgrounds than humanities and
that's we also have way more stem people
apply
and we don't really look at people's
backgrounds as a as a let's say um we do
look at people's entrepreneurial
backgrounds have they be have they
tackled hard problems before have they
tried to solve some inefficiency just
out of their pure you know frustration
with it um
but you know there's
we haven't had as many uh soft majors go
through the program we definitely have
that sun we've had some people like
there was one founder who
um was building a company kind of like a
mint.com but for
um um for minorities um instead of using
a web platform using cell phone just
texting um but yeah we've had them but
definitely not definitely not as much
another question yes
you said stanford doesn't take any
equity how does the
is there any licensing deals you know
within stanford um
i mean if
to some extent yeah so i think the
question you asked is does startups
doesn't take in
equity and you're asking if there's any
licensing deals with stanford is that
the question
is the question whether stanford has any
ip interest in this yes
okay yeah so startx is a legally
separate entity from stanford
and so there's no issues with licensing
and we don't take any ip
so if if a phd
does research at stanford and uses
material resources
stanford independent of startx owns a
part of that ip um and so that's kind of
an independent process from startx
yes
it would be interesting to hear from
each of you if there's a single
personality trait that attributes 200
success
so the question is
is there any personality trait that
you've seen contributes to the success
of a founder
so so thomas edison was asked once
it took him about a thousand times to
figure out how to make a light bulb and
he didn't say he failed 999 times he
said he learned 999 times how not to to
build a light bulb and i think that's
really what's key about entrepreneurs if
there's one thing is you have to be able
to deal with failure because that's what
that's what the whole learning process
is about
and and i think that's what the support
of a place like startups offers for you
as somebody mentioned earlier um you
know entrepreneurs and startup companies
are roller coasters and you're going to
spend a lot more time on the downside of
that roller coaster going then it seems
like you're on the upside so i'd say if
there's one thing i would say about and
this comes from being a venture
capitalist and being in startup
companies myself it's there just has to
be perseverance and i think that's the
one overly writing characteristic
um so i think this might be a little bit
more
random i think for me the most valuable
characteristic was empathy i never
thought this would be important coming
into doing a startup but i think it's
been incredibly helpful when it's come
to recruiting to finding investors to
finding my co-founder and keeping
relationships um startups are very rocky
and what that ends up doing is it ends
up
making you question you know the kind of
decisions you're making and who you're
working with and having empathy at those
points of time and not really
pointing fingers and taking a step back
and
talking through things can be very
helpful and instrumental towards making
sure that you grow this thing out before
beating it to death in the beginning
yeah perseverance and empathy are far
and away my number one and two same
reasons
i think i have a slight um um variation
of that
which is
actually it's kind of like it is it's
that it's the combination of
perseverance and empathy what i was
thinking is as a founder you have to be
okay taking risks and failing and
thinking of that as learning just like
milt said um and you have to have this i
call it humble confidence
and it's a it's this trait where
you're strong and you could you can
inspire people to follow you
because you you're not afraid of making
tough decisions or taking risks but at
the same time you're constantly
listening and you're constantly trying
to learn and become better and using
every single opportunity interaction to
learn something and so you're both
humble and extremely confident
on that note we're going to have to call
this to a close but please join me in
thanking this fabulous pal
you